WILL WILLIS: What you have there
are two stacks of high carbon
high quality steel.
The red is 15n20.
The yellow, 1095.
Now, I'm sure you know
that you're probably
gonna have to combine those into
some kind of Damascus pattern.
It's time to find out
about our parameters.
Your tang must be a
through-threaded tang.
Keep in mind that in the second
round, you'll be attaching
handles to those
blades to turn them
into fully functional weapons.
Your three hour forge
time starts now.
DWIGHT: Everybody
asks, well, how long
did it take you to make that?
I don't know.
I made it till it was right.
The challenge in
Damascus steel is just
making sure that you've
got a good [inaudible]
from the start.
--it's gonna get
hot enough or not.
What you want to do
is get your layers,
and get them heated
up hot enough.
It looks just like you
frying grease in a skillet.
A lot of people think
that it melts together.
No, that's not true.
They're wanting to go
together, but you've
got to put pressure on it.
And when they do, they'll bond.
[hammering]
MARK: So, in the first hour,
I want to make sure that I get
my twist pattern Damascus made.
That's going to be the hardest
part of this challenge.
Want to make sure the billet's
stacked, get it drawn out,
put it in the vise,
and twist it up.
Making Damascus is
difficult, because you're
forge welding, which is
a very ancient technique.
There's a lot of things that
can go wrong with a Damascus,
so it's pretty tricky.
WILL WILLIS: You think
Mark's worried right now?
Well, I mean, he's up
against three master smiths.
I'd be pissing my pants.
MARK: I'm somebody
who enjoys challenges.
Crossing that point of no
return, I really enjoy.
I fought an MMA fight.
I rode a bull once, also.
If you look for a reason
to say yes to something,
life will be more fun.
BILLY BOB: After cutting
the bar into four pieces
and stacking it up, pressing it
down, and drawing it out again,
I think I may have bitten
off more I could chew.
But one good thing about
making shark's tooth
is you know you've
got good welds in it,
because you have
tested them severely.
[clang]
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, shut down your
machines, drop your tools,
this round is over.
[music playing]
[bleep]
I'm not feeling really
good right now, because I
forgot to thread the tang.
It's a disaster.
All right,
bladesmiths, the first
round of our pick-your-pattern
Damascus challenge is over.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Mark, you're up first.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
DOUG MARCAIDA: So what
I like about your design
is that you have a false edge
that should back up the tip.
And you cut the thread in.
Good job.
Thank you.
I like the fact that I can
see the pattern in your blade,
all the way across.
There's a just a
bit of a warp, it's
more pronounced on the blade.
It will be interesting to
see if it moves forward.
Thank you.
WILL WILLIS: Billy
Bob, you're up next.
Phew.
BEN ABBOTT: It's got a really
nice shape to it, Billy Bob.
I like the fine point.
It should be a nice stabber.
I like the pattern
you put in there,
it's very easy to
see the raindrop.
Biggest thing with this would
be, you know, just getting
that tang straightened out.
But, good job.
Thank you.
Dwight, you're up.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well,
Dwight, overall
it's a fine looking blade.
I can see the pattern of
your ladder pattern Damascus,
it looks good.
Thank you.
It kills me that
that's not threaded.
What happened?
Just focused on
trying to get it
done, and just ran out of time.
This is, in my opinion,
the best finished blade here.
I mean, that's
just a really good
all-around knife shape there.
Thank you.
WILL WILLIS: Steve, you're up.
BEN ABBOTT: First and foremost,
amazing kudos for trying
such a difficult pattern.
STEVE: Thank you.
The pattern isn't quite as
visible as I would have liked.
But there's no threading
on this one, either.
Correct.
You do understand that this
is one of the parameters,
and not having it is
something that's serious.
I absolutely understood.
Bladesmiths, in
a competition where
failure to meet a single
one of our parameters
is grounds for immediate
elimination, two of you
are on the chopping block.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
[music playing]
Steve, your blade
did not make the cut.
David Baker will explain.
Steve, we've put these
parameters in place
so we can judge
the knives equally.
Two of you did not
meet those parameters.
Yours was just the least
finished of the two,
and that's the reason
we're sending you home.